la menace plane de nouveau sur la
centrale nucléaire de zaporiza après que
des tirs d'artillerie ont été lancés
dans la matinée de dimanche sur le site
Moscou et Kiev s'accuse mutuellement
d'avoir bombardé la zone première
version celle du ministère russe de la
Défense selon qu'il est fort
ukrainiennes ont tiré plus d'une
vingtaine d'obus de grands calibres
entre deux blocs énergétiques samedi et
dimanche
c'est le toit de ces blocs qui auraient
été visé selon Moscou qui assure que le
niveau de radiation restait conforme à
la norme dimanche le régime de Kiev ne
cesse pas les provocations afin de créer
la menace d'une catastrophe à la
centrale nucléaire de zaporigia
de son côté lucrena accusé les Russes
d'organiser une fois de plus un chantage
nucléaire le directeur général de l'IA
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
atomique a quant à lui dénoncé une
situation totalement inacceptable peu
importe le responsable de puissantes
explosion secouent la zone aux aporitza
la nuit dernière et aujourd'hui des
experts de la UEA signalent plus d'une
douzaine d'explosion et certains
bâtiments systèmes et équipements du
site sont endommagés mais jusqu'à
présent rien de très grave pour la
sûreté et la sécurité nucléaire dimanche
la compagnie nationale de production
d'énergie nucléaire d'Ukraine et
nergoatome à relever des dégâts sur
certaines infrastructures nécessaires
pour la production d'électricité du pays
ciblé par l'armée russe depuis mars 2022
zaporiza est officiellement passé sous
contrôle russe en octobre dernier le
président russe Vladimir Poutine en
avait ensuite revendiqué l'annexion par
un décret depuis plusieurs mois déjà
Moscou et Kiev s'accuse mutuellement de
bombardements sur le site situé non loin
de la ligne de front